we've got a voicemail number two one
nine to david p one of my favorite a a
favorite in that it's so ridiculous
pro-gun talking points came in via
voicemail take a listen to this
hey david this is kevin i live over here
and nebraska and i support the Second
Amendment but I've seen this meme going
around about how Hitler was able to get
round up the Jews faster is because they
took everyone's guns away what are your
thoughts about that and if it's true or
not
yeah listen this I I don't have an hour
to go through this I've studied this
quite a bit it's been pretty heavily
debunked the idea first of all it's a
false premise and in fact there was a
long period of time during which there
were during which Jews were allowed to
own guns in Germany then there became a
period where there were restrictions on
Jewish gun ownership of certain types of
guns but by and large there was no major
gun seizure for years and years and
years during the early stages of World
War 2 and the Holocaust and Nazi
persecution of Jews and just google it
it's it's widely debunked the idea given
the full scope of what was going on in
Nazi Germany and the indifference that
so many had to what was taking place the
idea that Jews with rifles and handguns
which by the way many of them had we're
going to prevent the Holocaust from
happening it is one of the most widely
debunked false notions of the pro-gun
fetishists maybe someday we'll do a deep
dive into it it probably does warrant
more investigation but it's just simply
not true we've got a great bonus show
for you today out of time to tell you
what's on it but it's a good one we'll
speak to you then